League of Legends is a popular online
game and Christophe sites his life
better known as an rated he's under
contract with SK gaming it's one of
Europe's top teams the german player
can't say how much he earns but as a pro
gamer he does well it's a full-time job
with long hours kind of an oilskin dozen
students I spend between eight and 12
hours at it most days before a major
tournament though it can get up to 14 or
16 hours that's when you get the bare
minimum of sleep take short breaks to
eat and apart from that you're playing
it's nothing I don't you try to get to
the point of perfection Apple
compliments like episode perfect sooo
many players only spend a few years at
the very top along with team spirit and
talent a pro gamer needs excellent
concentration skills and reaction times
that's also what British coach Joe loc
is looking for it may not sound that
hard but when you're pressing different
like several different buttons at once
they're like several different processes
going on in your brain and you got to do
this for a long period of time so the
other thing that you need is like a
really high concentration level in the
US egames are very popular the Robert
Morris University in Pennsylvania even
offers sports scholarships to talented
players the best are celebrated like pop
stars they take part in tournaments with
participants from all around the globe
the League of Legends Championship
Series is underway right now all around
the world it's the qualifier for the
World Championship here in Berlin the 10
best European clans are battling it out
crystal science and his international
team are also here their final briefing
the championship is a matter of prestige
with prize money in the millions for the
team the tournament is exciting but also
stressful sports psychologist lukashenko
helps them cope with the pressure Don
Gita's had a few know when you win you
analyze what worked and when you lose
you try to figure out why that happened
to so part of my job is helping figure
out why things happen without a
realistic and objective way that helps
give the players more control over
things opt vs Adeste Fidelis a Vulcan
Tony encode now the match is just a few
seconds away
here on stage the members of SK gaming
are giving it their all they're playing
in front of an audience of several
hundred fans but the live stream goes
out to hundreds of thousands of viewers
SK gaming finish the game decisively
congratulations sk custom science is
basking in the victory but at 23 he's
already one of the older players he
figures his pro career will be over in a
year or two but he's not worried about
what the future holds by this mr.
William in unstable down I have plenty
of options I could go to university keep
working in the field or maybe work for a
hardware manufacturer so it's not
something I'm giving a lot of thought to
right now what I'm doing now is pretty
tough and stressful so it has to be my
focus I think that's hope my man self
makes him good for now Christophe has
his next goal in mind he's shooting for
the World Championship title with his
team later this year shift says it's a
tough job but someone's got to do it